hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
sat here with adam
this guy you came to my crash course you
were 21 dude
yeah 21 years old you're now full
time in property respect congratulations
thanks very much um
and you've got you've got a really
unique property business
yes so congratulations firstly so much
making great money yeah it's good yeah
and from manchester
yeah you thought by coming here today
you'd be getting away from the nasty
weather but it's still a nasty house no
yeah
how does it feel to be just sat here
winners on a wednesday full time in
property did you expect that
no i mean i mean i've worked my
background is in i worked in solvency
the corporate world for four years
and then um i've always wanted to do
something more than the nine to five
um i've always been quite
entrepreneurial uh so
it was actually my brother who um found
you on youtube so
and then as soon as we found you sign up
to the crash course how old is your
brother
twin brother twin same age yeah i'd say
amazing amazing
so you came down to the crash course
with your twin brother yeah
and i mean what was that like for a
start what was the experience
like there yeah it's good i mean the
first day we're up at six o'clock so
we're pretty tired under the foster the
first day nine a.m to 11 p.m
so yeah knackered but yeah it's all good
um it's just an eye-opener really
yeah what did howie give eight money
with a little capital obviously you're
always gonna have to have some
um but it was enough for us to get
started in the deal sorting scene so
yeah and yeah we just so it was an
eye-opener
um and yeah we just thought after after
the crash course you feel dead inspired
and that
you want to take action straight away
and go and do it but then
if you wait a couple of months after and
he sort of dies down in
a bit yes so it's important to say get
the company
started get compliance and make sure
you've done something yeah then you you
feel obliged to go and do it then
now the thing is as well with you adam
is you you are the definition of an
entrepreneur you know you're the kind of
guy
you've got lots going on and we've been
speaking just beforehand about some of
your
other ideas and stuff you've got going
on you're a deal sourcer but you're not
just a deal sorcerer
you're also you've you've brought into
social housing the whole
refurb you've poured people in family
members to offer project management
so you've really created a unique
proposition to investors yeah and i
think that's why you're winning i think
that
you know yes i teach people the process
what to do but you've actually kind of
taken that but you've adapted it you've
chewed it up and you've made it your own
which i really
commend you for doing that yeah so say
if we have so for example done eight
deals so far
if we've got eight deals that all need
refurbs i mean we're
a project management fee but i'll be
working hard for that project management
thief i've got to bring
all these different contractors in all
these different areas yeah so what we've
done is we've created a refurbishment
business
where um so it's me my business partner
who's my mayor and my directors with my
dad and my uncle
so my dad and my uncle are builders by
trade so they've come in
uh on on full-time basis to do all that
refurb for us and project manage them
or give them 20 share all they need for
to be incentivized to get them done
quickly efficiently
and they're intensifiers to make money
that way so then i can be more hands-off
out we can concentrate more on the
sourcing
and if they're incentivized by the money
the the proposition to get off the tools
themselves project manage
that means that we can hopefully get the
processing procedures in place and then
suck
ten houses a month at them and they'll
be able to cope with it yeah and then
we're all making money
as a family so yeah and this is still i
mean you've done well you've done eight
deals
yeah and and for most people they might
think our deal in deal packaging world
is two or three grand
for you it's a lot more than that yeah
so for
for a bite we've done four by two let's
uh on our feet for a bite that's two
point five k plus bar a fee for hey
we've done four hmos
three four beds and a six bed yeah ultra
social housing our fee for hmos four
grand plus that
and then our project management fee is
ten percent of the refurb costs yeah
minimum of a thousand pounds so if it's
30 grand refurb our project management
fees three gun plus bar
right um so that's the way we work it
because
i think you're paying for a service we
believe our service is that good that
that why wouldn't you pay his hands-free
the investors don't have to get involved
the money goes down to his bank account
and we sort everything out you don't
have to come up north
to see it yeah yeah it's great it's a
good model and
where are you finding your investors
from that's the key question people
always say to me yeah you know
how do you find investors where where
are you getting these investors from
so i was in work and we'd obviously got
the company going and
we basically smashed social media so we
were just cold calling
uh says insta linkedin did you and your
brother right
yeah yeah aston mar uh or the business
partner okay
um so we so we got compliant we
incorporate the company in january 2020.
got complaint in march 2020 then
coronavirus here
so we're satellites are stuck but that
corona virus are all working from home
we all had time to build the brand get a
logo sorted get our social medias up and
running
you know get everything sorted so that
when we're having
when we can go to investors one would
look professional but then be open and
transparent
look we're new to the game this is our
business model and thankfully just
being in touch with investors who have
given us a chance because we're so open
and transparent with them they like the
idea of what we're doing
and the our first couple of investors
were already doing basically doing what
we do in the northeast they just want to
branch out to the northwest so it's a
perfect fit
all right talk me through very first
deal
okay yeah how did it come about what
happened how did you find the deal
how did you find the investor how did
you get the money so investor
through uh social media where uh
linkedin
okay how how did that come about just
basically messaging everyone
under the sun who you think could be a
wealthy guy and could be invested in
interest invested in property okay so
you did the you were that annoying
person on linkedin
yeah but you send you'll send 50
messages and you get one lead out of it
you've just got to be persistent
okay so you're sending people messages
on linkedin who look like they're
investors they look wealthy so good jobs
yeah
okay and you're just saying hey if
you're interested investing in
manchester i'm your boy yep
so the first investor we got was a guy
who
uh was basically he owns a dental
practice in london
and he's uh already he had three offers
accepted tries to cover it and they all
fell through
uh but that obviously he was coming up
north doing it himself
so he found other news and then he
hadn't heard of the social housing idea
and stuff like that so
um so he thought you know what i'll give
you guys a go
and then so we've yeah we saw him on the
social housing
um and he was he was so all about
manchester city and manchester center
but the pride after the after cover the
pro
the prices have just gone up
ridiculously it's so competitive so we
found it so we saw him on the social
housing side and the rent in
the first one was a buy site in the
world the rent was pretty good there so
um yeah so i left work on the end of
august and then
we got that offer accepted on the 9th of
september so
pretty much a week later what comes
first what comes first the deal
or the investor i'll tell you what a lot
of people say the deal but it might be
no way it's the investor you need to
know what they look for
yes why would you go looking for
something yeah
and not have someone to agree buy it i
agree all you're going to do is you're
going to find a deal
and then you're going to not be able to
sell it and then you're going to upset
the estate agent well that's the thing
because we're getting a lot of
we're getting a name for ourselves and
say in certain areas and they know we
buy
cash because we'll do a lot of hmos on
the social housing lease
uh they know we buy cash but there's
been another deal sourcer
going around he's put 22 offers in in
the areas we're looking
on the social housing scheme or you
can't find investors of the
solicitor stage can't find investors to
fund them they're all following through
and they're coming to us
he should have done the training well
yeah he should have done he didn't do
the training that dude but he's
upsetting all the estate agents yeah he
won't even take offers on him anymore we
could we call people like that [ __ ] uh
well exactly yeah you know because what
they honestly because
these people same with all the
strategies with lease options we've rent
to rents with deal sourcing with hmos
they do it wrong yeah they go out and
they
and they and they saturate and poison
but that's the thing so these people so
for example in manchester
like around the city center sometimes
they won't take a viewing
off a deal source or no or prove your
phone's upfront
and everything like that which is no
problem for us because when we sign an
investor before we start looking we're
going to sign our contract
proof of funds needs to be provided id
for money laundering we get everything
up front so we know they're serious
yeah not messing around yeah so we've
never had a stage where we put an offer
in we get the investor involved before
we put the offer in so we know he's
buying that deal
we never have to change names or
whatever we've never had an estate agent
annoyed with us because we've pulled out
we've always gone through everything
we've done
yeah so so they're coming to me and i'll
say i've got this do you want it
i think it's so important that that you
don't sabotage your relationship with
the state agents
the kids they are key yeah and you want
them passing you off market deals
you know so that's really okay so you
message a bunch of people on linkedin
and i'm going to ask you if it's okay if
you just send me the screenshot of the
actual script that you were sending oh
yeah no problem
okay the same the same every time all
right that's going to flash up right
about now somewhere okay
so so you send linkedin messages bang
bang bang
someone responds and says i'm interested
yeah then what happens you pick up the
phone
so yeah arrange a call the keys to get
them on the call for example yesterday
i had a barrister uh based in london
talk to me i thought only was only on my
phone for half an hour
and after the call she'd vote within
half an hour she had a voice she both
not
voice noted all of her barrister friends
in her office
who now subsequently have all got in
touch wanting to buy from from us
for real like literally and i don't know
if she's impressed with me or the the
concept or the business model or
everything that returns everything well
either way after one conversation
without even
you know not even buying from us she's
already recommending us
love that love that and then again we do
a referral thing probably if we do a
deal with one of her referrers and we
can
sort okay so that's how you get your
investors have they all come that way
from linkedin
um no obviously referrals now yeah
referrals we
bet we barely go out now and find them
with the alchemist it was yeah
just for you so posting on social media
showing people what we're doing
that's dude can i just say this is so
inspiring because you are
22 yeah you came to the crash course at
21. i'm getting all of these
like grown-ass men that are like in
their 50s saying to me i can't find any
investors
i think you've got the right mindset i
mean we i come from a business
background as you know
works in the corporate world i've got an
idea of finances i've got an idea
for a living i worked with businesses
that didn't do well as in they were they
were going into liquidation
administration
so i know exactly what not to do yeah
and i've learned from them no but you're
flipping the cards you're taking
and this is what everyone has to do you
have to say what if i got going for me
yeah not what if i got going against me
not because you could have said
i'm um i'm 21 i'm 22. i got i've never
done this before
yeah i i'm young i've got no track
record i got no but instead you said
actually no
i've done business stuff my job i've got
this
i'm young which i'm going to flip into a
positive and you focused on what you did
have
then delivered fan investors delivered
well now you're getting loads of
referrals people coming to want to buy
from you don't make deals and counting i
mean i spoke to
i just watched three new investors
yesterday to be honest i knew from
straight away from the calls they
weren't serious yep
one guy searched our company on
company's house you saw we were young
he goes i don't know where the uh your
chances are you're actually quite
impressive young lads and i was like
well
i don't need you i've got so many
investors right now if if you want me to
send you
before and afters of refurbs and when
we've completed the process from start
to finish no problem come back in three
months
yeah um i don't i'm not going to try and
convince you that i'm good at my job
that's absolutely right you're not
you're not there to try and convince
people and that's the thing if investors
call you up and say like
it's the same with me yeah like if
someone's trying to get me to convince
them to buy yeah i'm like no
you should be trying to convince me to
sell to you i mean i think the process
just sells itself anyway yeah the whole
thing that you're hands-free
and the fact of the matter is that
you've got people who are willing to
give you the chance
and obviously your first investor you
might have to
take a reduction in fees otherwise you
if you go
charging five grand a deal at the start
you're never going to get anywhere like
your first investor you need to treat
them well
um make sure they're serious obviously
but if you need to take a free reduction
in the first couple to get a track
record to post on social media to get
everyone you know
great do that because you know what in
the long term thing you just said it
you just said it long term yeah this is
a long thing hundred percent you know
people go into this thinking i wanna get
rich really quick or i wanna and
things can happen quick you know you
what month did you come to the crash
course i think it was september
well it was cold i remember that it was
october 20th the birmingham one october
2019.
prior to the crash course so you've done
any property deals any property
experience
no i mean i've been my dad taught me
when i was younger to like do kitchens
and bathrooms with him
yeah i didn't like manual labor so i
wish i learned i wish i'd
you know took some things on board but i
didn't but now he's doing it for me
anyway
you're right he's working for you doing
jobs for you oh yeah um
well yeah apart from that no property
knowledge or anything so so
you know within a year what you've done
is massive you know full-time property
you're doing deals you're making great
money
but it's taken time yeah as you know
yeah so
and you're playing the long game yeah
nothing's gonna happen overnight
yeah i mean in terms of me going full
time and where i am now two months old
crazy it's going so quickly but we'll
again long term is we're
we've planned everything out so we've
got our sourcing company and we've got a
holding company above that so
it obviously i'll take a modded salary
out of the starting company but all
dividends get put into the hole in
companies to invest in property
ourselves or
i mean we don't want the passive income
just yet we're young but we'll we'll
make that pot as big as we can
yeah by flipping flipping flipping and i
love your business ideas love that maybe
when we're 30.
we've got a big pot then we invest and
look after the passive income yeah and
i'll sit back when
i don't know when we're further on in
life yeah we're hungry but
why would we want passive income now i
get it i get it you're 22.
what um what made you want to come on
winners wednesday
firstly just more it's a more exposure
isn't it as in
i can i can a lot more people will see
what we're doing yeah
and again like i say you you get i know
you've got a lot of stick from the bbc
and stuff but
i'm generally just normal just a normal
lad from beverly in manchester
and then without i can say honestly say
without gwen stack crash course i would
not
be in property or anything i'd just be
my job still yeah um
yeah on a modest wage so yeah that's
awesome
and that's what i do want to do man yeah
exactly satisfaction and
and everything um so someone that's
watching you
just maybe 21 yeah that's thinking i
like
i like this guy i want i wanna i wanna
get some tips i wanna follow in the
footsteps of
what advice would you give to your one
year younger self
firstly well firstly go to the crash
course just to get an idea of all the
strategies and stuff like that
i mean and don't do all of them at once
just concentrate on one firstly
but also get we've got we've had a a lad
who in bradford who
has been doing what we do for the
basically for three years
he's at my age get on well with him and
he's helped us out massively so
find someone who's doing what you're
doing and sort of yeah and just ask them
to
um just ask them kind of just i can have
an hour call with you to see what you do
your processes and stuff like that
and also like he's benefiting from us
because three of the eight deals were
were sent to him
um because for example we got we got an
offer accepted at 71 grand on a
four-bed hmo um and then three weeks
later
the vendor came back said no i want
which is a bit naughty
um so our investor out of principle uh
said no i don't want to i'm not going to
go ahead
so i just said right give me give me a
week i'll find your investor for 75
grand
went to mummy and then he had an
investor he wanted it but because he's
been doing it long and he's got the
the um he's got the track record he's
got the investors
he sold it for double what we would so
we didn't take a fee cut
yeah so you know i mean you know what
that's the power of environment
yeah you know environment is stronger
than willpower i totally agree with what
you've said get the knowledge for sure
which you got from the crash course and
from the training that you've done at
the video and stuff
but then also get around people yeah
that are doing well that are winning
because if you're if your uh circle are
all broke and are all losers and they're
all bums
you'll probably be the next one yeah
exactly i mean one thing that helps as
well is there was a
a guy at my work you you went to your
class cause and stuff and we used to do
we used to go out every lunch time and
talk about property
and just constantly talking about it and
then um yeah
just give it people encouraging you to
to leave work but one thing i would say
is
to my old self is don't just leave work
if you've got no company no compliance
no investors no nothing
make sure in my last month of work i had
investors
pestering me for deals so i was like
just give me a month i finish in a month
and i'll do full time
so you need to be at that stage before
you even think about leaving work in my
opinion yeah
i agree with that how much has your
company done then in the last month
well i'll say from the last two months
well we've done four deals a month so
um the sourcing company about 20 grand
project uh refurb business
is 10 grand in project management fees
uh but he's looking to turn over 150k
already incredible man yeah incredible
you must be pretty proud of what you've
done
yeah i'm proud yeah it's good to get uh
you know uh
next step is obviously getting uh my
brother my mate out of work as well but
what's there's no point i'm coming out
yet there's no place don't make there's
a sense yeah to flood the company with
three big waves well not big wages but
three wages
yeah um so be good when you've got
someone with me you know to uh
how does life compare now to when a year
ago when you were working
it's strange because it's weird how much
you can see when you're not sat behind a
desk for 40 hours a week
yes and you can just go out in the as in
i'll wake up i know i might not
necessarily know what i'm going to do
that day
as in i'll do a bit of admin and then i
might get a coffin stage and come to
this house or go and view the house or
i might go to you know have a few calls
with investors
but at the end you get a lot of so you
might have weekends where you have to
work so you might have to go and do
stuff on saturday and sunday which might
not be normally
so if you do get a bit of free time in
the week don't feel guilty about
going to the gym going doing something
you want to do because
you're always sweating you've always got
to be switched on yes one thing
what we pride ourselves on is the
relationship with our investors
if they text me they get response apart
from saying now because i'm doing this
but
i'm driving they get response straight
away yeah they never have to wait more
than
unless i'm driving five minutes so i get
back to them
i think it's more it's like lifestyle
when you're an entrepreneur
it's not nine to five when you've got an
office job it's just i work nine to five
then i switch off then i watch your
standards
yeah do my thing i know it's different i
was never like that as in even when i
was working in
insolvency i was always trying to go to
networking events work and on that front
yeah
um so i've always been trying to make
more money somehow yeah and thankfully
my brother found you and then this is no
this has been the
the thing that we've gone for and your
brother's here right now as well
who's watching this yeah what's the
what's the reason why then what's the
strongest reason why you're doing all
this
at first i thought it was money i
thought you know what i'm just obsessed
with money
but then now it's changed like because i
could have
i could take all that money out if i
wanted to but i don't like
it and i just take him two grand a month
now just sit on two muk two animals net
i don't need any more um obviously use
it more for white and more wiser things
um but my why now is just to you know
have a good life just have to have
options have freedom
as in like i said we want to work out it
may as well work hard while we're hungry
it's exciting now
but when we're 30 maybe we might be
looking at looking at it thinking you
know what we've got
a million quid if we invest that at 20
there's 200 gram passive income for us
we might we have the option to never
work again in our life
yeah which is great which is why i think
anyone would like
absolutely and even then you'll probably
find that you're still working like
crazy yeah
definitely you do yeah and it's like
i've given my dad and my uncle a great
opportunity to run their business how
they won
their and at their current jobs so my
dad was on his aeros contract
um he needed to be employed to sort his
mortgage situation out which we've
helped him with um
but ideally they both wanted to be off
the tools so they can be on the tools
now from two to three
years but if they want to grow that
business so that their project
management full-time
they can do that help them out massively
what does your dad think what do your
family think of this whole thing i mean
obviously it's helped them out but it's
kind of crazy you're so young
listen when i was your age i was doing
the same sort of stuff yeah yeah so to
me i don't actually think you're so
young
because yeah i'm only 29 now yeah
exactly um but people watching this
you're probably thinking he's so young
yeah yeah like what do you
what do your family make of everything
you're doing
that is varied i mean i've not i've not
really taught obviously my mum and dad
and my uncle now
all know my mum doesn't know to what
extent we're doing
keep her in the dark she will real soon
she's there no
she's not seeing this other than figures
of all mind um
me dad he's very he was skeptical at
first but now but
i went to live with him for a couple of
months because whilst we were doing it
and he heard the conversations with
investors estate agents he's been to all
the prophecies now he sees
he's got he's planning ahead of what
materials he needs to buy and stuff like
that
yeah and my so he he's now so
open-minded of growing the
refuge as big as he can my uncle's a bit
more pessimistic but i think we need
that because we're all
go forward but yeah devil's advocate
cool um
but yeah i'm pulling him around no doubt
about it as in he's working
if when he sees that you know that part
of money building he's got 20
stake in it then yeah yeah it will come
he'll come around to saying give us more
out give us more properties to refurb
what do you think uh your mom would
think if she knew that
you know your business has turned over
like 150 grand in the last couple of
months well that the thing is that's
just the reefer business as well
like yeah it's crazy um i think she'd be
proud
and but she saw that she's got her own
cleaning business as hell so she knows
she knows and she knows it's stressful
and stuff
yeah and it is stressful it's not easy
at all yeah you've always switched on
there's there's not many down times that
you have um
see where you just completely switch off
so that's one thing that i'd say is that
to anyone thinking it's an easy ride
it's really not
yeah you know what i think about that
though i think that everything's hard
working nine to five is hard being a
plumber is hard having a community is
hard being a property investors
like if you're going to work hard anyway
you might as well get rich exactly i
mean in my nine to five job if i were if
i
smack like worked like crazy i don't
have the same wage but if i just
scrolled through social media for three
hours in my day
i get paid the same yeah there's no
purpose to what i was doing yeah
as in now everything i do is to make
this brand look as good as it can
if i do something maybe a bad decision
it affects me personally that's what i
want i want to be accountable for
if i do something great i'll benefit
from a lot of my money yeah exactly
so that's what i want i want it the
amount of that i put in is what i want
out of it rather than
i just get a basic paycheck every every
month yeah and as well
with what you're doing you're doing what
you're winning now you're making great
money now
making more money now presumably than
you did in your job right plenty yeah
a lot more plenty more okay so you're
making more money than you've ever made
but also you're growing your brand yeah
you're building up
the investors that that you build you're
going to end up doing joint ventures
with them yeah i mean the thing is is
we've got a few business ideas in the
pipeline and we'll go into that more in
a year's time when we do this again but
um if i wanted to borrow 100 grand off
them and give me the 10 return i could
get it tomorrow you know because they
trust me
yeah and that's that's the way it is i
mean a bit
i've always try and help other people as
well so for example one of my investors
i've got a mate who's
whose business model is to lend money at
fix rate investing himself pay them off
so i'll put him in one of my invest in
touch with him yeah um because he's
helped me along the way
um and also like for example my old firm
i'm referring all these investors that
we're getting now
if they have any tax advice or
accountants or
mortgage brokers that's where i've come
from i've just i've just come from a
firm that does all that
so now even though i've left that firm
on good terms i'm
and i i wanted to win work for them
while i was there but now i'm out in the
open i'm
preferring so much words then yeah
loving it amazing
got a meeting with a managing partner
there next week and all the partners
they're now looking at
oh my investment you know yeah so even
though i've left them
they're still in touch they're still
they're interested in what we're doing
and could have
10 big partners who all want to invest
with us incredible well honestly i'm
really proud of what you've achieved
i'll leave a link to your with your
details in the description so people can
get in touch
and i'm just so excited to see the next
12 months
and i think we've done so big i mean 21
22 years old
we went when you're 21 yeah um it's
really inspirational
so no hats off from me no thank you as
well thanks for everything yeah
why don't matters mate guys if you
enjoyed that please do us a massive
favor
smash the like button we do this every
single week every single week i
interview a success student that's
winning in property that's had their
finances revolutionized their lives
changed
through property as a vehicle and if you
want to one day be sat here and doing
doing interviews like this you want to
be successful
i'm going to leave a link in the
description with some links to some
online training mentoring
check it out it's real it works i look
forward to seeing you next week
thanks so much for watching